Exclusively on Hulu and Disney Plus
Kingpin thanks you for your loyalty
Viewer discretion is advised
on January 9th.
All five episodes.
One killer drop
I wouldn't have it any other way.
Don't miss Marvel's most intense series yet.
Maya
Enough games
If you want a war
you'll have it.
Marvel Studios Echo
all episodes streaming January 9th at 6 p.m.
Set your Disney Plus profile to TV-Ma to stream
Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie Marvel dropped a brand new Echo trailer
It's coming at the beginning of January
There's a whole bunch of Easter Eggs here,
a whole bunch of brand new daredevil and kingpin.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
but part of the idea as you see during this trailer
is that you see echo and Kingpin having to reckon with
their origins or their relationship with each other
in the idea that Echo has two different families
that she has to make peace with her
natural Choctaw family because she is a Choctaw Indian.
it seems like a really big part of the series
takes place when she goes back to her hometown,
then her family with Kingpin,
who's sort of like a surrogate father to her
or Uncle Kingpin, however you want to think about him,
with them, basically having it out
over the events of the Hawkeye series in the idea
that he killed her father or had him killed.
but in all the flashbacks
you can kind of see that he did care for her in his own
kind of way like a father would care for a child.
but when you're the kingpin of crime,
it's like the most toxic relationship ever.
Which is why she grew up being the way that she is.
it's a lot of the series is her
just making peace with all of that
starting with probably the biggest thing
first here this brand new daredevil footage.
It looks like he's wearing the red suit
and it looks just like the one from the Netflix series.
A lot of people wondering about this.
We kind of got into this during the She-Hulk series
when Daredevil came back again
and was wearing the yellow
and red suit part of the idea.
But then bringing Daredevil back into the MCU,
like starting with Spider-Man,
No Way Home, even though he didn't wear
any of his daredevil suits during that.
when they sort of bring him back as actual daredevil,
like in the actual suit,
they started giving him a couple brand new suits.
So that was the whole thing with the suit maker
during She-Hulk is that he made him a couple new suits
and he was there in Los Angeles to pick them up
and help him out with his legal problems.
one of them was based on the yellow and red one
from the comics with the initial daredevil costume
when he first debuted in the comics.
now it seems like he's wearing a new
but old version of the red suit,
like it's still based on the Netflix suit.
Even the yellow and red one
was based on the Netflix suit.
I think part of the idea is that when the series picks
up, even though Daredevil
isn't like a main character, mostly
just kingpin in Echo or like the main character's
part of the series
obviously takes place in the New York City area.
Like you see this explosion with the New York City
skyline here next to the waterfront,
when the series is going on
Echo and Kingpin are dealing with all this
craziness is going on in New York City.
And that's how they run into Daredevil,
because Daredevil is still keeping an eye
on Kingpin, ensuring
that he doesn't rebuild his power base.
After the events of the Hawkeye Series.
part of the synopsis says that while she's making peace
with her origin story, her past with Kingpin,
their paths, so to speak, resurfaces
through the black knife cartel that comes after them.
the Black Knight cartel is a really big
criminal organization based in Colombia.
The kingpin had dealings
with when he was running the tracksuit brothers
in his criminal empire or fledgling criminal empire
during the events of the Hawkeye series.
Up to that point, at least, I believe that most of
the events in the Netflix series are meant to be canon.
So he has been kingpin of crime,
so to speak, in New York City.
but it was relatively brief.
He went down at the end of Netflix season
three like Daredevil was able to take him down.
during the events of the Hawkeye series,
we saw him running.
The tracksuit froze,
and he had a lot of criminal dealings.
It was during that period, I think, that
he had dealings with the Black Knight Cartel
at the end of the Hawkeye series,
he gets taken down again by Hawkeye and Kate Bishop.
So he's lost his power base again, so to speak.
it seems like for whatever reason, like
something happens to set the Black Knight cartel off
and they come after Kingpin and after Echo.
So they have to band together, so to speak,
put their differences aside to help each other survive.
one of the other deep cuts, two from the Daredevil
Netflix series is the Black Knife
cartel was also really big in the Bullseye comics.
It was like a brief bullseye comic book where
it shows him going to deal with a black knife cartel.
I don't think that means that Bullseye is going to show
up during the Echo series or anything like that.
if he were to show up anywhere, it would probably be
during the Daredevil Born Again series.
But there's this longer fight that you see echo
having with daredevil in his red suit.
So it just seems like he's busy
watching what Kingpin is doing
keeping an eye on all of his dealings
and that's how he winds up running into Echo.
just starting at the beginning of the trailer footage
here you see Echo not sure when this is happening
in the timeline, but she walks into this warehouse
that's on the waterfront in New York City area.
You see the Marvel logo in the background
the couple important points
of information about actually watching the series
that they put in this trailer.
So they're saying that it's
simulcasting on both Hulu and Disney Plus
because Disney basically just bought Hulu
and they're slowly integrating it with Disney Plus.
So if you pay for Hulu and Disney Plus,
you might actually be able to watch all the Hulu stuff.
This is on the Disney Plus app right now.
eventually, I think the idea is that like you pay
one price and you get both services.
But at least. Right now for the beta.
I think you still have to pay for Hulu
to get Hulu inside Disney Plus.
Otherwise
you still have to go to like the separate Hulu app.
But I think part of the idea is that Marvel's
just going to do this with a lot of their TV series
now is that they'll just air it on Hulu and on Disney
Plus for the foreseeable future, just because
there are a lot of people that only have Hulu
or they only have Disney Plus, they don't have both.
they also state that in order
to get the Echo episodes on the Disney
Plus app, you have to set it to TV-MA in the settings.
Apparently that's just not like a default.
but this is part of the idea
with them doing Daredevil born again
as TV-MA a lot of other TV-MA projects
is that they'll release them under this Marvel
Spotlight banner that they're releasing.
Echo under Echo is just like the first big thing
is the first Big TV-MA series
that they've done under the MCU banner.
but it does make you way more hopeful
seeing this being so hardcore
that they can do that for Daredevil Born Again
in a lot of other series too.
but at the beginning of the trailer,
she walks into this warehouse that you see explode.
Later, you see the security force.
It looks like there was some party there
or something happened
like this is the aftermath of some party that happened.
love, the kingpin, shout out kingpin, thanks
you for your service.
There's just like a security force in the background
counting cash.
It just seems like people that are working for Kingpin.
when they open the door,
one of the security guards goes rogue.
He might be somebody working
for the Black Knight cartel.
so part of the idea here is the kingpin's power base
is in complete chaos
after the events of the Hawkeye Series.
it seems like she's trying to dismantle
this part of Kingpin's
operation herself to
we get a brand new scene with Kingpin Notice
he has both eyes in one is not damage
so this might be a flashback
this scene with echo reminds me of the first time
she debut during the Hawkeye series.
With that red light
just meant to evoke a lot of Daredevil
like a lot of Daredevil energy
just in general Then the warehouse explodes.
Echo might be the reason for that.
Like she might be the person that actually blows it up.
Then it seems like she drives on her motorcycle
back to her hometown in the Choctaw Nation.
there's a quick montage of a couple different scenes.
This woman going into labor could be in present day
or it could actually be Echo's mother,
because I think they're going to explain her
origin story during this.
There's some black and white scenes in.
There are some scenes that are just straight up
flashbacks, I think those all get into her
origin story in how they're going to explain her powers
during the series.
it doesn't look like she has her actual powers
in any of the scenes that I can tell.
but part of the idea is that
she's going to get some tribal tattoos if she doesn't
already have them, that will give her enhanced
strength, sharpshooting abilities, enhanced
speed, durability, they'll allow her to echo her powers
to her family members.
Thus the name Echo.
It won't be like her powers in the comics,
where her main power
in the Daredevil
comics is just copying other people's powers.
Echoing other people's powers.
she'll have actual low level
superpowers like defenders, level superpowers,
something that you would see in like the Defenders.
There's like Luke Cage level superpowers in another.
One of the abilities will be sending out vibrations
for healing in for damage.
the people that actually made the series at Marvel said
that they just tuned her abilities
up to make them a little flashier,
a little more comic booky.
but like I said, just in terms of actual power level,
it'll put her on par
with like the other defenders characters
that actually have powers, maybe not quite iron fist
when he's like fully powered up but close Luke Cage's
super strength is on par with Captain America.
Super strength.
Like, he doesn't have quite the level of powers
the Captain America has.
So it's like, around that level, Like,
not quite Captain America level powers.
not really sure what's going on here.
After Echo and Kingpin
beat the crap out of this guy on the airfield here,
then board the plane that's Echo in front of him.
You can tell by her leg
this is that flashback scene of kingpin
beating up the ice cream vendor
after he makes fun of a very young version of Echo.
I think part of the idea is that he beats him
up, echo witnesses it,
he freaks out a little,
but then Echo isn't bothered by it.
She's actually kind of enjoys it.
And they go get ice cream together after he gets done
beating the crap out of this guy It's
meant to give you a vibe in general for how the Echo
character winds up turning out the way that she does.
Like if she's not bothered by seeing Kingpin brutalize
this ice cream vendor,
then that tells you a lot about her character.
There's a real big fight scene here in the skate rink
where Echo takes down all these dudes here.
I'm not sure where this is happening.
This might be in her hometown.
Notice she has a couple of weapons hidden
in some of her prosthetic limbs.
very handy.
It would make sense that if she does this kind of work,
that she would hide weapons all over her body.
this scene of kingpin with the eyepatch on
is after the events of the Hawkeye series
the whole idea is that she didn't kill him.
It was meant to be right out of the comics.
And just like in the comics, when Kingpin comes back,
he has an eyepatch over at least one of his eyes.
it was meant to be ironic in that case,
because we're talking about the Daredevil Comics in
Daredevil is meant to be blind,
and now Kingpin had been blind, at least temporarily.
But he does wind up getting his eyesight back.
I think the idea is that by the events of Daredevil
born again,
he'll have both of his eyes working normally again,
not sure what's happening here.
Echo just seems like she's listening
to someone with her hands on top of a car.
This might be her about to be arrested just because
there are some cop car lights in the background.
one of these scenes here at the end of the trailer
seems like it's from that same building
where she wins the fighting daredevil
in the New York City area.
when Kingpin says if you want a war, you'll have it.
I think that he's talking to the Black Knight
cartel people, not to echo
one of the important details here
too, is at the end of the trailer, they say that
all the episodes will be available
to stream on January 9th, not on the 10th.
So they're doing the same thing
they did with the Loki series.
We're like, guess what?
We're actually releasing everything like a day before.
but I think part of the idea with the series
is because they've sort of rebooted the Daredevil
Born Again series.
Originally,
the Echo series was meant to have a much bigger
ending that pushed straight
into the events of Daredevil Born Again,
where Echo went back to New York City and she winds up
crossing over with the events of Daredevil born again.
what they might have done now is just tune things
a little bit differently in the ending.
So there's a little bit more ambiguous,
like there's a kingpin ending, there's an echo ending,
and then they sort of imply
what kingpin is going to be doing next.
speaking of the Punisher, a lot of people asking
if the Punisher is going to show up
because during the last big trailer said no bad deed
goes unpunished.
That just meant to be sort of like a come
to Jesus kind of situation for Echo in Kingpin.
Like, all the bad stuff that you've done
is coming to bite you both in the ass.
And I think that's through the Black Knight cartel.
I don't think that's meant to reference the Punisher,
But the Punisher is still meant to be
like a really big main character
during the events of Daredevil Born Again.
I think they're just waiting
to bring him back till that.
So if he does show up during Echo
be like a huge surprise I just did a much bigger video
about Spider-Man four
because apparently in the latest script for that
Daredevil in Kingpin or really big characters,
so it looks like we're actually going
to get our real big Daredevil
Spider-Man team up in Spider-Man versus Kingpin.
At some point during that movie.
but there's a whole bunch of stuff going on here.
If you saw any Easter eggs that I didn't talk
about during the video, just write them below
in the comments.
Big reminder to my what if season two episodes
will start posting next week?
They are dropping those one per day for nine days.
I'll do one video for every single episode
just like normal.
click.
Here for that brand new What If Season 2 trailer
video and click here for my brand new Deadpool
3 teaser video.
Thank you so much for watching
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!